after the New Hampshire primary I warned
Democrats that they didn't have much
time
Bernie won New Hampshire and won huge in
Nevada and then old Joe Biden won big in
South Carolina on Saturday remember
winning Iowa which Pete Buddha judge did
by a hair meant absolutely nothing he
dropped out last night
and Klobuchar today of course she's gone
both endorsing Biden now tomorrow is
Super Tuesday and the moderates they're
out of time for the progressives it's
Sanders and Warren and in the moderate
lane Bloomberg and Biden because of
early voting which we conservatives have
always been against Biden's Jill mentum
may be blunted Bernie's followers were
jacked up very early in this whole
process and if Biden does let's say he
does really really well better than
expected tomorrow well Bernie's at that
point in real trouble the Beltway media
will work to write off Bernie completely
and quickly but if it turns out the way
most people think and Bernie does well
tomorrow enormous pressure will be
brought to bear on Bloomberg to drop out
to help Biden out and frankly also on
Warren to drop out to help Bernie finish
off Biden and then prominent elected
Democrats they're going to begin lining
up for their choice now if they manage
to pull off this Biden rescue effort the
question is can Biden himself really
withstand the rigors of a grueling
campaign he seems to be having a lot of
trouble lately and it's pretty apparent
that if Biden wins the nomination and
somehow somehow beat Trump heaven forbid
he'd just be a figurehead president
doing whatever Washington wants and then
the swamp wins again it will be donors
who set the policy on China and
immigration and then throw a bone to the
hard left they'll get to pick the judges
a power coalition from hell if you ask
me now what we're seeing is the
beginning of the Democrat establishments
rebellion against the will of its own
voters they don't want Sanders a
socialist to get the nomination despite
the fact that he's the front-runner in
the
polls and has won two of the last four
primaries and caucuses but what's
happening to Bernie you think about it
is somewhat similar to what the GOP
establishment tried to do to Trump back
in 2016 they hated him they tried their
hardest to rally the party around Jeb
Bush but that dog wouldn't hunt
Jeb dropped out after South Carolina
even after george w nikki Haley and
Lindsey Graham all tried to stop Trump
there but guess what Donald Trump won
anyway and then Marco Rubio he dropped
out after Florida lost that that was his
home state then Kasich flopped yeah I
know you had forgotten about him right
well he flopped everywhere except Ohio
but he hung on until he lost all
credibility
it was so bad for him that he didn't
even speak at the RNC which was held in
the state in which he's governor but
watching everything play out over the
last 72 hours or so it's clear that the
Democrat machine is trying desperately
to claw back power claw back power from
the radicals that they let run free in
Washington for the last year they made
huge mistakes under estimating the power
of the AOC crowd over the last year and
of course the Democrat establishment
they're not helped by the fact that it
has a terribly weak candidate in Joe
Biden it was easier to defeat Bernie
last time even as Hillary Clinton was
physically collapsing in public it's far
more difficult to prop up Biden now who
is mentally collapsing in public
tomorrow superstar Thursday I was
waiting for a black man to pick me up
and take me a total of 147 miles south
to Washington DC to be sworn in as
president and vice president states to
America we call these truths to be
self-evident all men women created by go
you knows you know
thing all right thank you very much all
right it's Chris but anyway I just did
the fact is most of the excitement and
the momentum is on the left and it's
behind Bernie and it's reflected in the
polls nationally bernie is polling eight
points above Biden and his lead is even
starker and most of the 14 states set to
vote on Super Tuesday tomorrow he's
currently pulling on an average of 15
points ahead of everyone else in
California the state with the most
delegates Bernie's polling ahead and 8
of the 14 states set for tomorrow
meanwhile Biden leads in just four
states and in two of those states North
Carolina and Oklahoma his lead is a very
narrow one he's almost out of cash the
problem is a former vice president
two-term vice president obama's guy
should be just sucking in money he's
broke that shows a lack of enthusiasm
not just at the grassroots level where
you need where you meet what it needed
that but also at the top he's not
filling stadiums like Bernie Sanders no
he's not filling stadiums he might in
close he'd be lucky like it filled a
local Elks Club just look at the massive
crowds Bernie drew in California
yesterday the establishment is getting
very very nervous the corporate elites
corporate elite are getting nervous and
the political establishment is getting
nervous as well
and some of the leaders in the
Democratic establishment are saying my
god look at the turnout here
meanwhile Joe Biden he's just relegated
to I don't know after he wins in South
Carolina he did this little video that I
saw on Twitter where he and Jill his
wife were essentially begging for money
so going to suit all the time the whole
time you're the watching man
this is the biggest feel so far this
charism thank you thank you thank you
for your love and your kindness and so
we're going forward so can you can chip
in five dollars ten dollars because
we're gonna power forward and win this
race won't you help Joe oh no this is
this is sad the audio quality wasn't so
great either but it's just a
presidential campaign I was thinking
about this tonight Democrats know how
they love to screen power to the people
but in the end it may just be power to
the donors who were all pulling out all
the stops to end Bernie's second quest
for the presidency and reports tonight
say he's starting to bring in the cash
but Democrats should really learn the
lessons of history Biden is the new Jeb
except he's old and makes zero sense
both are kind of low-energy but nice
guys with good resumes neither generate
the type of excitement that successful
candidates for the presidency usually
need to have the Battle of November
should obviously be Bernie Sanders
versus Donald Trump not Trump versus
Obama nostalgia if Obama's policies were
so effective Hillary would have glided
past Trump in 2016 but Obama's policies
didn't deliver the rising wages or
business optimism that Trump's have and
for his liberal supporters this failure
has only driven them into the arms of a
socialist Americans deserve a real
choice capitalism versus socialism
that's a choice and letting people
decide for themselves will tell us what
the country thinks of Trump's America
first conservatism versus Sanders
collectivism may the best man not the
most influential bloc of donors win and
that's the angle